yeah we have those big nuclear warhead
kind of conspiracy stories in season 2
the ones I love are the ones where Brian
just goes in the song so he comes out of
your TV screen into your front room just
helps some middle American family you
know that the government has forgotten
about or they've fallen through the
cracks and he's he's making it his own
personal emotional investment to help
them out what does that mean for you
anyway when you transition into that
second season in terms of the heavy
lifting because obviously if some of it
was on other people's shoulders before
now it's all in your shoulders yeah it
is all on my shoulders and we're in
Toronto and it's minus 22 and I'm doing
18-hour shifts and getting beaten up but
in season one I was kind of an actor he
did stunts it was made it obvious to me
by my stunt coordinator and season two
he said look we can let you do
everything this year you know we're
gonna treat you like a stuntman and and
that's not Sam you know there's there's
loads of people that teach me the
choreography to keep me safe so I'm not
one of these actors like I do ever do
myself but I've done all the stunts
apart from one big explosion and a
couple of little things that Dan my
amazing stunt double who teaches me the
stunts who steps in on front of the
camera but long story short the
mythology of a stuntman is you don't
complain if someone says you're care you
go so all it's changed really is I go
home to my wife and my kids and I'm
swearing and I can't walk and I'm
getting into a bath of epsom salts you
know either you have to take it home
with you you can't let it out on set you
know otherwise they won't let you do it
not to mention a warm-up because it is
super cold the drummer oh it's crazy I
was doing a scene the other day and I
couldn't even move my face was frozen my
eyes were frozen which is secret to keep
warm do you have anything besides keep
moving or nothing no just just just kind
of gritting your teeth and just you know
swearing on the inside so this you know
take it was a huge show you know it kind
of Liam Neeson is almost synonymous with
that did you get a chance to talk to him
about this that about this show and
about the franchise
yeah I did when I first got the role I
was filming Vikings in Ireland and
Vikings won some Irish TV and film
awards at the festival and he all got a
Lifetime Achievement Award so a man to
sit at the same table and he was more
interesting to me Vikings rather than
taken because he said he's a big fan of
family which is great but yeah I did
talk to him it's the same kind of things
for him the reason why I wanted to take
the role is there's a lot of action
shows out there and there's access to do
it really well there Jason Statham's de
Vin Diesel's in that but it's just pure
popcorn action and I'm not
I'm personally not interested in
performing in that kind of TV show or
film but the character Ryan Mills is
just all about heart it's about that and
I'm a dad and you don't have to be to
relate to him but when that dog is
screaming and he's the only person that
knows how to get her back you're you're
in there you're emotionally connected as
the audience and that's it that's all I
wanted and that's why he took that role
and that's why I took the TV version
do they know dad's a superstar actor yet
my 14 year old 11 year old a 7 year old
14 Rose it's like yeah that's never here
yeah they don't think it's cool it's not
really about I mean I look at other
professions when you can kind of come
home at 8:00 at night and you you only
get to tuck them in at least when I'm
unfinished is about I'm kind of daddy
day care I can take two months at home
and just make up for the time I white
you mentioned you mentioned Vikings
there's you know obviously people are in
love with your character on the show
you're revisiting the franchise what can
we expect from a story arc when you go
back to the Vikings oh well anyone who's
a fan of Vikings or anyone in loves or
loathes Rollo for hopefully the right
reasons will be able to agree with me
when and so whenever roller comes back
or whenever Rollo is you're expecting
him to do one thing you always have to
expect the unexpected the Rollo
so there is some there's some past
problems he hasn't dealt with there's a
certain there's a certain person that he
never got together with he needs to tell
something to before he dies there's some
unresolved things but again don't expect
the obvious with roller never expect the
obvious we wrote do you enjoy that you
know now that you're you know you have
your show do you enjoy going back to
that franchise and kind of just join
yourself you know your story arc you
know how many episodes you there you
know what's going on is that I mean it's
that fun I don't know I mean really
truthfully it's really it's really tough
leaving any show for a period of time
but I mean you have you also need to
know when's the right time to let go and
you know Ragnar and Rollo together that
was vikings for me and and i i want to
and you never want to outstay your
welcome and i think you know it roll is
still in the show and and and and
there's a story to tell as long as
there's a story to tell and I'm there
but they just felt the right time to
kind of move on in history for Michael
not just me but for Michael has the show
right
to tell a different story and it has to
be of another sons of Ragnar now and I
feel like like the new Ragnar Rollo it
was that was one generation and us
standing on the baton it's great you get
to exist and to complete it from realms
oh it's amazing
I was fantastic yeah I mean yeah I'd
love the fact that I was involved in
Vikings it's it's one of those shows
that doesn't come along very often it's
it's not been number four and this feels
actually certainly it's gonna be with me
as one of the best experiences of my
life
thanks very much appreciate it all right